hi I'm Eric Vox and this is a breakdown
of Legion third episode chapter three
and this is somehow both the scariest
and the sexiest episode of Legion so far
and I'm pretty messed up so to me scary
and sexy are pretty much the same thing
I'm going to break down all the visuals
and miserable stuff in this episode as
well as some new stuff from the first
two episodes so let's get started with
these opening images and as usual
there's a lot to unpack in this opening
montage so let's talk about the visuals
first so David is singing two types of
images first there are the dark intense
shots of division 3 with Amy being
tortured with leeches David sees all of
this through the screen of one of those
video monitors at the division at this
he's complicit in Amy's pain and to
represent David's fear for his sister
our good friend the devil with the
yellow eyes comes back meanwhile David
balances all these dark images with warm
Pleasant images of things that he likes
like childhood memories and whoa steamy
shower nude so this balance reflects
David's attempt to set his mind at ease
focusing on saving his sister Amy while
also keeping that fear from completely
overtaking him and by the way the reason
David is visualizing the shower shot
specifically is we learn later that ever
since he swapped bodies with Sydney he
can still physically feel what it was
like to be in her body so as he showers
he feels himself bathing her body which
is why we see both of their bodies
process of solving into each other and
this isn't just pervy shower thought
there's actually an important reason
that these two share a physical
connection which I'll talk about later
also notice how throughout this montage
we hear the voice of the eye aka Walter
saying
several times over and over we also see
some repetition of the shot of David's
dog fetching the ball
so all these opening instances of
repetitions set up the recurring theme
of repetition throughout this episode
like a lot of what we see in this hour
are shots from before replayed in
David's memory and when you repeat
things over and over you begin to notice
patterns and connections that you
wouldn't have seen otherwise kind of
like how I watch these episodes of
Legion eight times and begin to see eyes
everywhere like hi hi everyone hi
similarly David needs to repeat
traumatic moments from his life over and
over so that he and Melanie can begin to
interpret meaning from them and another
important theme is set up in the
woodcutter story anyway have you heard
the story I was a poor woodcutter and
his wife told to us by Oliver the voice
that we've been hearing throughout
Summerland facility now speaking through
this quirky Rube Goldberg coffeemaker
now Oliver is voiced by Jemaine Clement
and we learned this episode that Oliver
was Melanie's deceased husband who built
summer land with Carrie anyway this
story is about a curious woodcutter and
his wife ruining a good thing by trying
to observe its magic the lesson being
our insistence to understand natural
phenomena leads us to lose what's good
about it in other words curiosity kills
the cat or defection kills the frog or
picking at the crane scares away the
crane just leave animals alone guys and
in this case David is the crane in the
story the magical creature who can do
great things for Melanie meanwhile
Melanie is the curious woodcutter trying
to exploit David's powers and analyze
him too deeply and actually I think the
show set up this crane back in episode 1
in that shot with David sleeping and
clock works there was kind of an odd
shadow moving on the other side of the
wall which almost looks like the wings
of a large bird maybe operating a loom
course Melanie doesn't yet see how her
curiosity will come back to burn her so
she pours out her coffee and starts the
story over again only through repetition
do we find meaning and before I move on
there's this quick shot of the two
carries Carrie the MRI technician and
Carrie the other mutants who rescue
David in episode one now we knew from
last episode that something was up with
these two like their names sound the
same but or so
differently and they have the same last
name Loudermilk which I don't think is a
very common last name and there was that
moment last episode when Carrie seemed
to be talking to himself and then in a
later shot the other Carrie appeared in
the room and then now the mail Carrie
seems to absorb the female Carrie as if
they're both halves of the same person
who can split into these two identities
maybe one brain and the other brawn okay
moving on to this memory work session
and notice how the table they sit at has
a large X across it maybe this is just
me seeing patterns where there are none
but when they go into this memory
Melanie realized david has the power of
telekinesis so this X might be implying
that Melanie sees even more useful miss
and David as a future mutant warrior
with the x-men and yeah that's assuming
that the x-men will be part of the
timeline on the show which is very much
not a guarantee now when they go into
David's memory of the fight that led to
this kitchen incident notice how when
autonomy tries to move them out of it he
gets blocked and David says he's not
doing it and this is followed by one of
the creepiest ever appearances by the
devil with the yellow eyes so what is
going on here well Melanie and autonomy
cannot see the yellow eye devil here
only David can and I think that means
that devil wasn't in David's literal
objective memory he's a separate
identity and David's present-day mind
that's corrupting his perception of the
past and maybe he's doing that as
David's current lingering fear haunting
each of these moments that he was most
afraid as he looked back on them he
thought III don't know I don't remember
it's just
fear and the fact that the devil with
the yellow eyes can prevent putana me
from leaving this moment shows that this
identity is a powerful controlling
influence now I know we don't like to
look at the devil with the yellow eyes
for too long but a few things to point
out here one look at his clothes in the
past he's worn something that looks more
like rags or a potato sack but here it
looks like a suit and tie actually it
looks a lot like the schoolboy clothes
worn by the angriest boy in the world
figure so since both the angriest boy
and the yellow eye devil are terrifying
demonic figures that haunt and chase
favorite memories I'm wondering if
they're actually just one in the same
with the angriest boy being a cartoon
version and the yellow eye Devil being
what happens when that cartoon is
transformed into something more
human-like kind of like those creepy
human versions of The Simpsons
remember those gross right and one more
quick thing to point out about this
devil is notice how he keeps getting
larger and larger each time we see him
like the first episode he appeared small
like in the background of frame and then
last episode he appeared larger getting
closer to David and now we're getting a
pretty damn good look at him and a lot
of people pointed this out recently and
it's amazing so I gotta mention it we
actually saw the devil with the yellow
eyes in the first seconds of the very
first episode as a tiny toy on Young
Davis floor and notice how when the
frame dissolves into another shot the
toy holds over by itself creepy
so this devil with the yellow eyes has
been haunting us from the very beginning
starting as a small adorable creeper and
then evolving into a bloated terrifying
threat and this memory work session ends
with David teleporting the three of them
into Melanie's office and notice the
window here another X in fact it's the
same X through the circle and the O of
the Legion logo and it's interesting
that this session revealed two of
David's newly discovered powers to
Melanie and it was bookended by these
X's possibly suggesting David's future
where he could put these powers to use
okay moving on to my favorite scene of
the episode with David and Sydney joking
about all the dirty stuff they put in
each other's bodies and other than this
just being a grounding character moment
it's important to set up that David
still feels physiologically connected to
Sydney but also notice how Finney says
this line oh my body you know
how come to think about it anyone can
just come and go
like this fall no one knows for sure
doesn't exist and I've got proof more
than just this but everywhere I go I'm
me and this is the exact opposite of
where David's head is at his mind is
filled with hundreds of identities and
he's never sure who he is so I think
that's why he's so drawn to Sydney with
her one sole mindset she represents the
constancy and stability that he wants so
badly okay moving on to David's lab test
with Carrie and notice this exchange
sorry I know you were a bit of a lab rat
at Division three I'm sorry
Chubby's this connects back to that wood
cutter story the dangers of curiosity
like the woodcutter Carrie is about to
again see the harm in looking too deeply
into David's ability also notice now
again female Carrie appears out of
nowhere seemingly emerging out of male
carry pack and assuming these two are
halves of one person male Carrie seems
to be the cautious analyst
while female Carrie seems to be a bit
more emotional and impulsive like notice
this judgy pink eye that she gives
Sydney after she reassures David I think
this means that the carries do not like
having someone else having an influence
over David outside the control of
Summerland okay let's move on to this
Halloween memory there's a lot of
interesting things going on here first
there's this sign in the background with
David's name written Shaklee on it now
I'm not totally sure what this is but
maybe it's meant to imply that this
whole memory is young David's property
the way kids write their names on books
and toys and since this is his childhood
property maybe we're not meant to
interpret this literally the way that we
can't really trust anything we see on
the show then notice David's costume
he's dressed up in what looks like an
astronaut or a spaceman of some kind
that could be something he picks because
his dad or his father figure told him
that he was an astronomer and David just
loved space but remember in the previous
scene what Lenny kept calling David's
girlfriend and as true
approach Kyra can the reptile speak
Hopkins maybe that means that David's
girlfriend like everyone in the past
perhaps is another identity that he
created in his head although what
exactly is his dog's name like every
time these kids have said it it's kind
of stuff like King but then when young
David looks through the fence here he
clearly says cake and remember what
David said in that earlier scene so
either that vapor enhanced his ability
to smell a store-bought cake in a box in
another room or maybe part of him is
referring to his lost dog and really I
just think the point of all these
connections is to intertwine all of
David's past trauma the night he lost
his dog leading to this scare from the
angry Explorer in the world and then the
day his kitchen exploded leading to this
scare from the devil with the loi also I
love the ways that this moment warns us
of the scare that's come in first as
David hears his dad reading the story
his voice is overlaid with the demonic
voice of the devil with yellow eyes his
face turns lame and then there's that
creepy little music thing that we heard
in the first episode with the devil and
then last episode with the bedtime story
and then finally notice how when david
approaches the fence the color of this
shot suddenly shifts to this yellow tone
now obviously color is a huge part of
Legion and the color yellow along with
those audio effects I mentioned are
connecting this monster with the yellow
eye devil monster which I'm thinking
more and more argh yeah the same monster
now back in the lab David's present-day
mind is haunted by Lenny who makes David
feel paranoid about Melanie and guilty
for what might be happening to his
sister who knows how many commandos is
gang banging your sister right in the
corn hole now it's interesting that
Lenny uses this crap sexual imagery here
and I think it's because David's mind
lately has been fixated with other
sexual imagery with Sidney and Lenny is
trying to make him feel guilty for
having those pleasurable sexual thoughts
by turning sex into something negative
you know just an armchair psychologist
here also notice how Lenny briefly
transforms into a me begging David a
saber but really just taunting him
recipie
about to say dick maybe it was me but
this reminds me of that one scene in The
Wizard of Oz where the Wicked Witch of
the West pretends to be on a em just to
screw with Dorothy this work scare the
crap out of me as a kid like how is this
a kids movie now to this epic moment
when data flows out of the chair I've
talked a lot about color in the show and
again notice how the light flashes on
David and Sidney faces flickering from
red to blue now this show is used red
light in the past as an alarm signaling
something bad about to happen
meanwhile I've been noticing that blue
light might be a place of comfort for
David specifically with Sidney remember
in episode 1 that reflection kiss moment
and clockworks
they were both bathed in this nice blue
light until the scary red light snapped
David out of the moment
I think a similar color effect is being
used here we have Sidney trying to
anchor him in the blue light but the red
light taking him out of the moment and
then when David and Sidney Astro project
to where Amy is held a few things to
point out here first this old man from
episode 1 quotes
Amyas saying can you want to carry your
husband it felt like you grew up in a
haunted house so not only did ami know
that David's issues weren't just mental
problems but actual supernatural
abilities and I guess you just blocked
this out the idea of the Haller house
being a haunted house sets up the whole
horror movie aesthetic that closes out
this episode also notice that the clock
on the wall has no hands actually I
think we saw this before too maybe this
is one of those things like how there
are no clocks and casinos to make it
easy to lose track of time and in this
case it's a mind game that these
torturers are playing on Amy but it
might also be like an aesthetic choice
to distinguish this place from
clockworks
and clockwork so is all about putting in
the time and fixing your brain so that
it runs like clockwork here in Division
three time is irrelevant they're not
trying to fix anything only hurts and
control and contains we also get a clue
for why Walter it's called VI notice how
he's able to see David and Sydney's
astral projection so I'm guessing that
part of its power it's sensing when
mutants are present or using their
powers and when David and Sidney
teleport back to the Summerland
waterfront notice this close-up of
I droplets in the water now this could
be depicting the dye that Kari injected
into David to track a stress hormone but
this shot also mirrors the close-up of
the vapor droplets that Lenny dropped
into the Frog to get high last episodes
but in this case the shot is moving in
Reverse so this could mean that instead
of that destructive downward drug trip
that David took with Lennie David is now
experiencing an upward reverse trip with
Sidney okay let's fast-forward through
Melanie explaining the history of Walter
the eye and Oliver in Summerland and
their plants who's today David and
David's vapor trip dream and talk about
this moment between David and Sidney in
the bathroom
notice what David says when he quotes a
therapist the word monster
not to be a monster he first guys do
something monstrous so David is
struggling with his guilt and his
identity issues he knows this monstrous
presence exists in his mind but he's
learned that that inner demon won't make
him a monster unless he acts on it so if
he can control his actions and rescue
his sister he will know that he's not a
monster and again the colouring of the
scene is awesome connecting back to
David and Sidney's relationships the
yellow light covers part of David's face
reflecting the nagging fear that the
yellow-eyed demon will take over and
turn him into a monster but when he
turns to Sidney he's connected with her
in this calming blue light and he's able
to leave that Maggie and yellow fear
behind him okay moving on to this crazy
memory work sequence with David under
sedation
now I should say that all of this is
definitely reminiscent of the Nightmare
on Elm Street movie specifically dream
warriors because in that sequel the
heroes are mental patients who band
together to go into their nightmare
together to investigate and defeat the
demonic boogeyman Brady Krueger and
obviously that's pretty similar to what
David and Sidney are doing here now
earlier this episode mentioned a haunted
house and I love how this final sequence
connects all of David's fearful locales
as part of one impossibly designed
haunted house
there's dr. Poole's office David's
apartment and his childhood home all
under one creepy roof and this scene
here hint set this whole spatial link
with this clever transition with the
camera floating through the Summerland
window into the alleyway outside as if
they were right next to each other okay
so Melanie explained
that the reason David is a child in this
memory is that his defenses are lowered
from the sedation because they still
think it was him blocking them before
not the yellow-eyed demon so instead of
a grown man he's depicted as a weaker
innocent young boy and again it's
important to see David and Sidney making
physical contact here because I think
it's that physical connection from when
they swap bodies is a reason why Sidney
can see the devil with the yellow eyes
while Melanie of autonomy can't like
when David's mind went into her body so
did the ability to perceive all of his
inner demons now in David's memory of
robbing dr. Poole he sees these
projections of himself Poole and the
recording of their sessions autonomy
realizes that they're seeing memories
was in memory as junkie David realizes
that he needs to destroy the evidence of
his relationship with Poole and when he
goes into those recording files notice
the names on the other tape now I don't
know who Robinson Abernathy or Dirk's
Unger are but I'm guessing that plaza is
a reference to Audrey Plaza Lenny
with mr. a possible reference to the
fact that the character was originally
written to be male and it's confirmed
here that the shot of David eating
spools of tape that we saw in the first
episode are indeed happening in this
moment and this might just be me but
this reminds me of another horror movie
moment from the ring when a woman had
that electrode cord down her throat
it's just unsettling to see people put
in or take out these things that don't
belong in their mouth and then as this
memory transforms into a legit haunted
house with this unnerving image of the
yelloweye devil pushing through this
hellish fissures in the wall check out
how this widescreen cinematic aspect
ratio returns in episodes 1 & 2 the show
uses visual to suggest a sense of dread
in danger and this moment with young
David and Sydney in the memory of David
having sex with his old girlfriend is
interesting like before David's
subconscious is trying to comfort
himself with sexual imagery and it leads
to this super awkward moment for Sidney
like kid kid you're either going to
traumatize yourself or freak out your
older self either way let's just go
watch cartoons okay and when the
angriest boy in the world demon chases
them down the hallway notice how it
becomes the yellow eyed devil once it
appears in the vent again more evidence
that these two are the same monster and
this whole scene reminds me of another
Nightmare on Elm Street movie Wes
Craven's new nightmare
so along with dream warriors new
nightmare is really the only sequel
worth watching that might be
like it's a crazy meta version of the
story where Freddie haunts the actors in
the movie Nightmare on Elm Street and
like this episode of Legion that movie
ends with the boogeyman chasing and
terrorizing a woman and a little boy
inside a nightmare and with Melanie
alone in the memory haunted house she
actually gets our first look at David's
parents or parental figures they look at
her suddenly threatened kind of like the
family in that house at the end of
insidious also notice how Melanie
follows the sound of the dog king or
cake or whatever it is whimpering inside
David's closet now again I think just
could mean something bad happen to this
poor dog and that could be one of the
dark memories that David is blocking out
and that brings Melanie to this book the
world's angriest boy in the world and
you may have noticed that that title is
redundant right like the word world is
in it twice and I think that's part of
the idea of repetition in this episode
through repetition comes meaning and as
Melanie tries to find meaning in this
book the devil with the yellow eyes
appears behind her and the book attacks
her disfiguring her hand as she pays the
price for her curiosity like the
woodcutter in the story but let's talk
about this closing shot and how it might
connect to the final page of the book
notice the illustration it's a town that
the anger exploit like it's set on fire
and as David remains trapped in his
memory he's assaulted by all these angry
voices a repetition of that shot that we
saw for episode 1 now remember in that
episode the old man in Division 3
mentioned Red Hook implying something
bad happened there since then we haven't
heard anything about Red Hook and we
don't really know what it is but I think
Red Hook could be referring to a town
that David went wild in like the boy in
the story in fact that might have been
what we saw in that opening montage
episode 1 with everyone rioting outside
a liquor store and it's possible that
all these screaming voices could be an
entire population of a town that David
killed or absorbed into his mind or both
and on the outside Sidney says this I'm
not so sure those are memory this
suggests what many of us believed that
the reason putana me and Melanie can't
see everything in these memories is that
not all of it is memory its various
identities in his head speaking to him
and terrorizing him right now okay just
one lingering question after this
episode is leads in to scary personally
I don't think so I love all the horror
imagery but it is another bold tonal
choice that makes this feel less like a
superhero show
and more like the aesthetic of something
like American Horror Story but obviously
with characters we actually care about
okay let me know what you think in the
comments and thanks for watching and
make sure to check out my breakdown so
the first two episodes - now I'm going
to try to keep up with these weekly
Legion breakdowns no promises either way
we're going to be doing more video
coverage on Legion but you can help us
make more of these by liking this video
sharing it around and spreading it far
and wide and if you like what we do here
at new rockstars make sure to subscribe
and if you like you can contribute to us
on patreon thank you so much all of our
current patrons we love you guys you can
hit me up on Twitter a DA vas with any
thoughts or theories that you have on
Legion or followed new rockstars on
Twitter at new rockstars for updates on
our videos okay thanks for watching bye
[Music]